we are under a strongly recommended
quarantine here in New Jersey things are
escalating we saw the governor earlier
say he thinks is gonna peak out 45 days
which means he goes in 45 days then you
could estimate one another 45 after that
before it's finally over
yeah three months yeah the peak so it's
like getting all the way worse
and then finally tapering that's saying
and we're gonna it is to the worst so
it's gonna get worse for 45 days and
dude we're about ready for the purge man
no I mean like the purge it's here yeah
it's kind of crazy how the story is yeah
yeah go ahead they've been releasing
prisoners early because there's a panic
that if the corona virus hits a prison
it's gonna be you know bedlam so they
decided to start figuring out who they
could release now until people are
getting their sentences reduced by a
month or so
it's not a big deal like I mean a month
but they're letting people go and the
crazy thing is that Philadelphia police
and this is freaky because we basically
live in Philly yeah will I'm gonna do
air quotes here delay arresting people
whatever that means for a certain no no
no that's BS they're claiming that
they're gonna delay arrests for certain
nonviolent yeah I'm pretty sure check
this out theft from persons is a violent
crime like if you came up to somebody
and you are like give me all your stuff
or else and I was like oh yes please
don't hurt me is that not violent yeah
well as long as it didn't actually hurt
you please so please give me all your
stuff please I stolen auto burglary
vandalism vandalism is literally defined
as violence really yes violent the
definition of violence is a destruction
against a person or thing person or
property right yeah yeah so vandalism is
literally violence mom I think I think
it's gonna get bonkers because we you
know you know what happened in San
Francisco and they were like we're not
gonna go after these offenses here we're
just walking those doors and filling
bags up and walking and then you know
obviously this is burglaries so wait we
can walk into anyone's home and just
like fill stuff well trespassing is
nonviolent that's true
taking stuff is also nonviolent although
you could get shot walking into
someone's house dude all the guns are
gone
it's scary well where are we right now
all the the guns are all gone because of
this I know this is insane man dude it's
like crazy they're almost at purge
levels so here they're saying they're
saying they will detain you and take
your information and then come arrest
you later when later in three months
yeah yeah they're gonna show up and
you're gonna back prove it seriously
prove it and they're gonna say and
they're in testify well you did this on
but no didn't I think that was three
months ago remember yeah yeah not even I
don't remember nope you're wrong
three months ago I mean whatever though
I I really don't think they'll follow up
either cuz they'll get so backlogged
yeah what are they gonna do up to every
single house from now they're gonna
ignore it they're gonna beckon me what's
the point that's crazy yeah yeah yeah
California Ohio and Illinois are letting
prisoners out how about that that's
that's like one step beyond that's like
you know you can complain they're not
gonna arrest you well what are they just
let you go okay early they're letting
them out early
right yes low-level crimes well I will
mention this man as a relatively you
know lefty libertarian type person the
prostitution one at the bottom
I gotta say man like if two consenting
adults want to go into a motel room and
do whatever I really don't care I don't
get that one
yeah all the others yeah you mean you
don't get why prostitution is illegal in
the first place yeah okay like it was
like well here's the thing
if I go on tinder and I'm you know I'm
swiping on some chick or whatever and
then she swipes on me and then she's
like y'all hook up and then we're like
all right let's go do it that's fine but
then if she's afterwards like can you
give me some money like oh now it's
illegal I don't understand like how do
you draw the line between her being like
I also need money to get home and pay
for food and if you are like yes I will
pay for your food and your car here is
$100 are they gonna what you know what I
mean well that's that's like a little
different because when you're when
you're a prostitute you say the price
this is what it is is what you're
getting right there's a fine line
between what so sorry so what you're
saying is I don't know hold on what
you're saying is that if a woman was
like yes I'd like to go to motel with
you will you give me $100 for food right
now and we'll go on
well it wouldn't be for food it would be
for sex no but you get the point it's
it's they can solicit it it's like what
if they said uh yeah what if I said this
I want a $100 meal I would like $100
meal please I would like an in-kind
contribution of $100 okay and then I
will engage in coitus so I'll go buy you
a hundred dollars worth of food and then
and then you buy them like a what so so
hold on do you think it's do you think
it's fine if like if a woman it says
straight up like I want you to take me
out on a really fancy dinner and then
you know if you want to hook up is that
okay
I mean there it happens I know but like
would that be illegal No so then what if
she said I would like you to buy me an
iPhone they're both monetary value also
happens and then what would happen if
afterwards you went return the iPhone
got a thousand bucks now what are you
gonna do about it
well they've apparently they're gonna
arrest you man that's the point because
what are you talking about prostitution
yeah what have you guys been doing while
you're under lockdown at her coronavirus
we're having the the the strong
conversations of the deep questions of
life yeah yeah the comment says we all
pay for sex directly or indirectly
that's what I'm sayin it's so dumb like
what if you pulled up to a chick and
you're like Hello man would you like to
be my long-term girlfriend she said yes
and then he said as you as you are now
my girlfriend I would like to lavish you
with gifts here's money now let's go
bang that's illegal
it's like how do you it's it's such a
fine line I think I mean I get it this
this you know they say you know it when
you see it look I think prostitution is
one of those things that it's gonna
happen no matter what
yep why is it it's gonna happen no
matter what what if you pit clean keep
it legal
although what if what if I said yo I'll
give you hundred bucks you give me a
high five I would take that high five is
that illegal it's such a weird personal
thing where it's like technically that
would be prostitution right what well we
have already crossed into the not family
friendly friendly portion of this
podcast so anyway this was supposed to
be about them not arresting people we
should probably read this and there's
probably tons of people who are like
Mike
are listening to this Fox 29 reports in
response to the kovat 19 outbreak
Philadelphia police officers have been
instructed to stop making arrests for
certain nonviolent crimes I love how
they call it nonviolent the department
said individuals who would normally be
arrested and processed at a detective
division will be temporarily detained to
confirm identification and complete
necessary paperwork the individual will
then be a will be a arrested what will
be arrested at a later date on an arrest
warrant Fox 29's Steve Keely reports the
non violent crimes include all narcotics
offenses all of them like so if that
means if a dude was selling dope to a
kid they'd be like your good buddy just
give us your name and we'll come for you
later and then super like all right dude
a kid would come over I'm not done the
cops are gonna walk off we're gonna do
like no seriously they'll probably take
the dope from no I mean all the Tayna
yes pretty sure they do that what
hopefully they're gonna that when they
detain them they're gonna do it you're
gonna go right back to slinging dope the
kids problem they're just like that's
the point of arresting them to stop them
from doing it you know theft from
persons is my favorite what kids are out
buying drugs right now everyone's dumb
warranting I guess that's true
you know what if it's a delivery service
right look I mean New York is a ghost
town
my buddy just left he's like I went to
upstate because he works at a restaurant
and there is nobody out and there's
there's articles going because like
everyone's gone everyone's staying
inside everyone's afraid you got you
went to the store earlier right I did it
seemed normal
it it seemed like everyone was doing
that I need to get all the stuff I need
the shelves were empty there was like it
was insane how much was he empty there
was no like I walked past all the way to
the back and you know you walked past
like the cheese and the deli meats yeah
nothing nothing zero yeah because I know
nothing there's no milk there was no
milk
do you get the bread and milk man I'm
sorry I got the bread now we're in
trouble
we actually are making our own bread I
don't need them out real we ran out of
bread hired a baker and so then we made
our own bread it's really good really
good
it's boiling me it's really good it's
really it's gonna be sorry go back I
know good like but it but it make it
like it's red gets moldy really fast so
we keep you in a couple days so it's
like you got to make it you got to eat
it like in a day mm-hmm but yeah man we
went to the store with you couple days
ago you went earlier yeah and it was it
was already just like white because I
was not touching anything and put gloves
on so I'm do like so here's what here's
what I think you know I noticed that we
actually had a really a really big show
yesterday last night the podcast yeah we
did one of the biggest live concurrence
we've ever had yes so I don't I don't
know why but I had a bunch of I had some
other people hit me up saying that their
YouTube traffic is down hmm
and I'd Pete some what some people asked
me like hey are you are your YouTube
views down and I was like a little bit
yeah but not like I don't know whatever
and then yesterday was actually like wow
that is really down and so it's
something that affected a bunch of
different people and often what I do
when I'm trying to what a lot of people
on YouTube don't get a lot of these
these people they don't understand how
the world works so you end up with these
youtubers who freaked out when their
views go down like what am I doing wrong
my video must be they get depressed and
sometimes it's just you know I don't
know people watching football yeah you
know right right like right now we do
the show at like 9:00 Tucker Carlson
comes on so we get a buck people dip out
for that know whatever time but a lot
Tucker who dr. Carlson no yeah so Fox
News okay so you know I I don't I don't
freak out too much I actually look at
podcast mmm numbers to see like is this
just a YouTube thing as YouTube's
oppressing me and it's not apparently
it's just across the board people were
not particularly active on you know
watching YouTube content and I think
there may have been a big thing
yesterday where people were like meet
with their families you know like you
said your buddy left New York and went
upstate yeah I'm sure about you went to
there what yesterday yeah I'm sure a
bunch people are like I'm gonna go home
and see my family yeah and then and I'm
having dinner hanging out playing board
games or doing whatever that's probably
what happened I hope so I mean look it's
affecting the whole country yeah it's
it's pretty intense and
and in philly theft from persons is no
longer arrest of all that's crazy I
would not want to be in filling out dude
you could be walking around Philly right
now and some can walk up to you to be
like give me your stuff okay
nay nobody gonna arrest me for it that's
crazy man
retail theft dude that is nuts are we
gonna start seeing more crazy are we
gonna see videos now where people like
going on Walgreens and just like opening
everything in a bad happen in California
so yeah so there's so for those that
haven't seen it the video in in I think
it's in the Bay Area yeah it's like the
three women in a Walgreens just
shoveling everything off the cosmetics
shelf into into bags or whatever yeah
and there's one woman screaming like
help help call the police the cops were
like for what that's what I was getting
confused with a b5 but that's what I was
talking about right I'm 47 I think
that's one called yeah yeah thanks for
not sternly saying my name theft from
auto no so what people can break into
cars yeah you're good buddy nobody's
gonna arrest you don't worry about it
burglary sweet yep there's gonna be a
lot of people getting shot from
burglaring houses yeah it's an
interesting actually I come in are very
interesting guns have been sold out you
know say the least like there's there's
one store there was one store I saw a
gun shop in Vegas and the guy was like
don't come to my store the everything is
gone like everything is gone he's like
oh whatever they could buy they bought
so right now you've got people dude this
feels like the apocalypse it really does
or you were saying earlier the purge and
like we're pretty close it's not even
that it's like dude what's silent killer
hold on is go ahead right right now
they're saying you could burglarize
someone's home not gonna arrest you well
they'll detain you and get your info and
then be on your way sir and these are
big I'm gonna go rob some more people
okay well we got your information just
you know will come to rescue later
well I mean being detained is means
you're probably gonna go to the stage
now or for a few hours they can detain
you up to 45 minutes that's two penalty
so that's Illinois I don't know about
anywhere else
I don't know Phileas or PA
hmm but detained usually means they just
hold you there and take your information
and then you leave oh so here something
like people are speeding ticket a cop
can stop you and say you've been
arrested you can't leave and they not
and then they can later say we're not
gonna charge you never mind
you can leave okay I have I was arrested
in in DC on the when Trump was getting
inaugurated that a big prep there's a
big protest okay
the cops surrounded 200 something people
and they said you are all under arrest
and I asked the lieutenant and I said am
I free to go I mean arrest he's like
you've all you're under arrest you are
not free to leave and I said okay and I
said I'm just why don't you know I'm a
journalist he's like well you can't
leave I was like no problem just letting
you know
eventually he he I you know talked to
him he pulled me and several other
journalists out and said you're free to
go and I had to talk to a lawyer and
they said yes you were arrested not
detained and then they decided not to
process you and bring you to the station
so there's no follow up charges or
anything like that a lot of people don't
seem to understand that there's arrested
and then processed
there's detained arrested process you
mean detained cop can stop you so you
can't go anywhere and he's trying to
figure out was going on arrested is them
basically saying you are not free to
leave under any circumstance because I
here detained they can hold you for a
certain amount of time okay if you're
arrested you can't go and they and they
they have reasonable suspicion you
committed a crime or they or they know
you did and then they take you to the
station to process you it's possible
they arrest you and then say okay you're
you get out of here so they're not
arresting people this is why this why it
feels like you know look the stores are
empty
people are mass buying guns the market
is tanking cops are now set people are
being released from prisons I mean
grocery stores the shelves are empty
yeah I mean you can't buy I mean
everyone knows you can't buy toilet
paper but it's getting pretty close to
not being able to buy and you know when
I was there with you and he says but
there's no bread oh there was even less
things there today it was crazy man Wow
and we went to Sam's Club and it was it
was even it was just as empty if not
more empty like wow it's Sam's at Sam's
like the frozen the frozen section like
there was no frozen chicken
Wow no frozen meat I mean I you know
buying it myself but you know I walked
past it I'm like there's usually stuff
in here and I'm like what is this though
is the chicken section gorap empty
you're saying your water section empty
what a tepee section empty
we couldn't find flour there yeah oh
flour we went to a few stores looking
for it zero and and there you know what
you know what I'm willing to bet there
was like some paleo and almond flour
mm-hmm you could've grabbed that there
was forget what kind of was I don't know
a small little bag for 30 bucks of some
crazy kind of flowers like and that's
not really kind of cut check us out
vandalism won't be arrested all bench
warrants all all bench we're all bench
warrants not your good stolen auto okay
so let's say this up you can be
smuggling dope that you stole from a mob
boss who owned a Walgreens and you took
it from inside the Walgreens and then
you go out smash the window of his car
drive it to his apartment
take his TV then spray paint on the
building F the police while already
being a wanted murderer driving away in
that car I'm pretty sure murder is a
violent crime no no all bench warrants
okay yeah Breyer and so then so then you
drive away in a stolen car with the
money took from the car while shorting
stocks that he owns and selling yourself
because you know then and and then and
then offering yourself up to him and as
you pull up to a stoplight and the cops
gonna be like just give me your name
buddy and we'll come deal with it later
we're gonna we're gonna come in about
once this all settles down we're coming
for you the cops gonna know that what's
the cops gonna say is listen buddy we're
gonna go over and chill it you know Al's
pub and wait for this to all blow over
this is this all I see here is them not
wanting to get coronavirus they're just
going yeah we don't want anybody on the
divorce getting this and we're not gonna
endanger our own our own essentially
that's how they feel like a family there
check this out the courts are also
closed we have this one from the
Philadelphia Inquirer with courts closed
by pandemic Philly police stop low level
arrests to manage jail crowding so this
is also about
you know they're not gonna be making
arrests but they're also straight up
saying the courts are closed you know
it's funny to see the lines outside of
gun shops and and like urban Democrat
districts it's like all of a sudden
these people learned real quick you
can't rely on the government mm-hmm it's
the weirdest thing they're like well
time to look at my gun now
you know they felt so safe and secure
when the government had everything under
control or at least the illusion of it
but you know I you know I often tell I
you know what I often tell people is
that they don't understand that
everything is just based on a precarious
confidence in the system yeah that's
true like how many cops you know many
cops there are in like up the town we're
in without saying the name probably not
that man probably like 15 yeah no no
probably 100 yeah I was gonna say
hundred probably like 60 to 100 yeah and
there's like 50 KP really isn't that
much it's not New York I think I could
be wrong but I think New York has like
8,000 at any one time and a total of
like 24 to 30 like 8,000 on on a short
on a shift yeah I could I could be wrong
at that doesn't even feel like a lot so
here's a nice tell people is it to
understand about about the precarious
nature of society
jiminee people how many people are on
Manhattan Island alone 2.5 million I
mean right now probably almost none but
well probably a lot less New York City
has like what 13 million people in the
metro I think in 10 million maybe 10
million it was 9 million yeah four years
ago so at some of the suburbs right yeah
yeah take 1% of that and have them
protest that's bonkers with more than
any council hundred thousand people
people storming through the streets
would be insane but like black violence
riots where the cops gonna do about
nothing their relief people don't point
one percent yeah but so you had 10,000
people that's what the cops know about
going toe-to-toe with them I mean
there's just not enough police they'd
have to call in everybody and now
they're openly telling people they're
not gonna be arrests let's say 0.3% 0.3
30,000 there's any a time to for people
to go nuts well it is now okay so is
this why I was part of the reason that
Como's calling in like the National
of course dude it is a precarious
situation where we all agree yeah the
confidence in the system what makes it
work is the cause that we agree on
things and once you get to the point
where people are running and buying guns
they no longer have faith in that system
they're no longer saying I have
confidence the police can help me do it
myself
yep great and then when the stores get
stripped and people are stocking up like
crazy every man for himself basically
it's a very human thing huh thanks for
checking out this segment from the Tim
cast IRL podcast we do the show every
Monday through Friday at 8 p.m.
sometimes an hour or two and we do have
a full live recorded version of the show
that includes a lot of comments and
smaller segments you probably don't see
if you want to check that out you can
watch live at 8:00 p.m. Monday through
Friday or become a member of this
channel and for five bucks a month you
get full access to all of the recorded
podcasts every day after the show we
make them available in the community
section of this YouTube channel so don't
forget to subscribe and stick around for
more segments and more shows Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next show
you